[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what the filing cabinet did that nothing
else had ever done before is allow loose
paper to stand on its edge i think i've
caught you up
1890 thank you heather invented 1890. so
i'm largely talking about the early 20th
century for most of this talk
um so what are the advantages of storing
loose paper on its edge i'll quickly
note two it's easier to retrieve a piece
of paper from a filing cabinet on its
edge than from a pile of papers right
and it's also easier to find something
specific so loose paper can be grouped
together with other relevant pieces of
paper regardless of when it was created
and in fact it was the latter that first
got me um thinking about the filing
cabinet
in research for my passport book i spent
weeks at national archives in college
park maryland looking for references to
passports and thousands of reels of
unindexed microfilm records of 19th
century u.s diplomatic correspondents
don't you wish you were me and so one
day though i arrived at records for 1906
that year is forever etched in my mind
because that year the state department
started using a numerical filing system
and so suddenly every diplomatic office
had the same number for passport
correspondence subdivided by specific
issues and cases and applications so
rather than scrolling through formally
bound pages organized in chronological
order i could go straight to where the
relevant information had been gathered
in one place so subject trumped
chronology right and this completely
changed my research and it made it
possible
to find documents i wanted with um
limited effort
okay i'm just trying to get the screen
going um um so my epiphany at national
archives was one about classification
but later it became about storage when i
discovered that the early 20th century
celebrants of decimal classification
systems the people who were excited as i
was channeled their excitement into
filing cabinets right the key was to
move away from storing paper
in bound books
so to hopefully state the obvious
the filing cabinet stored pieces of
paper but paper was where knowledge was
recorded stored and circulated so to
store paper was to store information to
make loose paper accessible was to make
information accessible
therefore to use the filing cabinet was
to interact with information
and that is why i argue the filing
cabinet is an important object to study
the filing cabinet allows us to
understand a fundamental change in the
way in which information was gathered
and stored and reused a change that in
its staying power continues to shape
interactions with digital information so
not only through files on our computers
or tabs on our browsers but i would
argue with
digital assistants like siri and alexa
where women continue to assist people to
find information so i acknowledge the
current contemporary stuff but this talk
is going to be pretty much a deep dive
into that moment of emergence
and i do that because um i think it's
important to acknowledge the power
relations that are integral
to
information technologies like the file
or the tab so rather than an
infrastructural tubes and wires critique
this history makes information and data
material by showing that the concepts
through which we are still asked to
imagine our encounters with information
and data files folders tabs etc
originated in highly gendered
understandings of labor and information
and so in that sense it kind of
re-embodies information by showing that
the properties of the information
technologies associated with filing are
the product of historically specific
power dynamics
so therefore like again general point i
guess i'm not so much of therefore yes
technologies have affordances they're
designed to do some things more easily
than others
um and in that sense i examine the
filing cabinet as an object that is
activated in particular ways it does
some things and it and not others
um in that sense i don't look at the
filing cabinet as being inert or frozen
right i think about it as an object and
operation as something that is activated
right it's understood to have emerged as
a solution to a set of problems problems
about the storage of paper
however as a response to these problems
it generated a set of processes that
affected thought and action so therefore
the other kind of sort of idea
underpinning this research is the
perhaps hopefully not too radical claim
that storage is not neutral right that
storage has a politics and of course
this raises a number of questions
including you know how is storage
constructed as a problem what values go
into deciding what to store where to
store it how to store it so what were
the problems the filing cabinet sold
right well as i suggested storing loose
paper on its edge allowed it to be more
easily retrieved both the specific
content on a sheet of paper and also the
sheet of paper itself
so that is the the filing cabinet
emerged out of a rethinking of storage
so in the 1890s in the office the
storage of paper becomes a problem of
retrieval
so storage always involves an awareness
of future use right but it does not
always prioritize the moment in the
future when the stored object will be
accessed what we now call retrieval so
as a practice of piling or stockpiling
storage prioritizes the allocation of
space to store something right storage
takes up space
in contrast retrieval is conceived as a
temporal practice right the focus is on
a process on facilitating the act of
finding something retrieval takes up
time right so why then is storage
approached as a problem of retrieval at
the turn of the 20th century why that
change well this period saw ideas of
efficiency capture the u.s business
imagination as capitalism takes on its
corporate form and scale in this period
saving time emerges as one of the
defining problems
of modern western society now in the
book this book prop this book
in this book i offer a detailed
discussion of the stakes involved in the
storage logic of the filing cabinet i
focus on three concepts verticality
integrity and cabinet logic is critical
to understanding its development however
all these
concepts or storage logics logics are
underwritten by a concern to save time
and increase productivity so in this
talk in the spirit of efficiency i'm
simply going to use efficiency um to
explain why i believe that the filing
cabinet is not a neutral
storage technology arguing that
efficiency is a highly gendered
discourse right at any period but
particularly this period
so efficiency creates the problems that
the filing cabinet solves
i say problems because the filing
cabinet responds not only to the problem
of timely retrieval but also the need
for information in the first place so
efficiency productivity require planning
planning requires information it
requires knowing what to produce and
when to produce it therefore information
takes a on a roll in business that it
had previously not had and i should also
notice the period um when management
emerges as a profession as well
so in the um remainder of this talk i
want to focus on two ways in which beer
efficiency
the filing cabinet shaped a particular
kind of interaction with information so
first i'm going to talk about how the
filing cabinet makes pervasive a concept
of information as a discrete unit as
something that exists in the world and
then secondly um i'm going to focus the
second part of the talk will focus on
how the filing cabinet brings to the
foreground a new mode of work used to
handle this information
information labor emerges as something
distinct from knowledge okay so the
emergence of the filing cabinet provides
an important site to examine a critical
moment in the ascendancy of information
as a defining
aspect of contemporary society right
to have an information society you need
to have a particular understanding of
information and information becomes a
name for an instrumental use of
knowledge
now as the late jeffrey number showed
the 19th century saw a move from
information as an individual mental
process to be informed to be
educated to a conception of information
that attaches it to something that could
be possessed and obtained and received
and distributed and circulated so
information increasingly becomes thought
of as a discrete unit now to be real
clear
i'm not arguing that the filing cabinet
invented this conception of information
but i am arguing that it offered a way
to make sense of this change right
became a way to grasp information both
physically
on paper and metaphorically
so this quote up here um comes from a
1912 issue of a long-lost magazine
called machinery and i like this quote
because it gives us a sense of this new
conception of information
so useful information here we can see
was carefully and systematically
collected and then it was classified and
digested digested not mean eat not mean
eaten but put into
digests broken up into pieces into book
within books that is information emerged
from knowledge through an increased
specificity right and and further
classification objective procedure made
information or allowed people to argue
that this information was superior as
the quote says to individual judgment so
this process of division took knowledge
and made it accurate information easily
understandable by anyone and as the last
sentence says instantly available
whenever a problem is presented to
management efficiency
timeliness
inside a filing cabinet a file drawer
showcase this understanding of
information in part because it used
tabbed guide cards and folders
i inadvertently bought a prop
middle of tab manila folder to make the
specificity um to make the specificity
and classification visible in its
organizational structure the file drawer
allowed information to be retrieved in
its specificity a piece of paper or a
manila folder
of loose papers could be extracted so
you had all the information on a
particular customer or product or
passport application information was at
your fingertips and this is the period
when that phrase um takes off
so the idea that info that you could
hold information not only that you could
see it but touch it as something
discrete goes a long way to explaining
how the filing cabinet
and tabbed folder became a conceptual
gateway to understand modern information
because of course information is
something discreet can be represented in
many different ways within a statistical
table right the cells on a table
or in this period that i'm talking about
the organization of a railway timetable
but these made the concept of
information harder to grasp as i'll
continue to pun on grasp through the
whole talk
um so as these quotes up here on the
slide suggest this tactile articulation
of paper and information frequently
appeared in prescriptive literature
the attraction of the filing cabinet to
the business information of the early
20th century was how quickly it allowed
hands to get out of
information it defined classification
therefore as a temporal problem as much
as a spatial problem right
classification is about efficiency in
the sense
we'll get get to that briefly but q a
yes okay yes yes lasted for four years
it comes up a few times yeah let's let's
yeah a lot basically as i should say
every sentence in this talk
is open for q a right this is a summary
of my book every source is open yes but
yes but thank you for drawing attention
to it slide um so ads claimed
a filing cabinet allowed users to find
papers at a moment's notice or almost
instantaneously in the spirit of the
time these assertions were quickly
quantified according to one very happy
customer almost instantaneously
translated to 20 seconds to find one
letter and 90 seconds to file
file five folders that's pretty fast and
we'll talk about the hands that are
doing that um in a moment and focusing
on a retrieval a filing cabinet also
challenged ideas of what defines storage
rather than hiding information in
drawers or in pigeon holes or lying flat
in piles this that that form of storage
was now understood to be dead storage
right so rather than that information
needed to be alive it needed to be
standing at attention there is no
subtlety in my archive um storage um was
not dormant or dead when you used a
filing cabinet
um in the 1930s celebrating the use of a
decimal filing system and advertising
agency president noted quote that
information does not rot in our files it
is continuously shuttling back and forth
between file and everyday business use
claiming that within a few minutes a
clerk could retrieve sales presentations
from 30 different companies in 30
different fields he concluded thus our
file lives
now stepping away from the specifics of
the file draw i want to note that the
filing cabinet and the interior of the
file drawer are examples of a key
technique of efficiency what i call
granular certainty and this is the drive
to break more and more of everyday life
and its routines into discrete
observable and manageable parts right
granular signifies the belief that
breaking things down um produces a
higher degree of detail or specificity
certainty indicates the conviction that
greater specificity will reduce
individual discretion and increase the
likelihood that a task will be completed
efficiently now obviously breaking
something down into small parts allowed
it to be controlled by enabling it to be
more easily apprehended understood and
connected to something else
this is the logic that is central to
taylorism and the reorganization of
factory labour occurring um according to
standardized tasks occurring at the same
time
now the analytic value for me of
granular certainty is that it emphasizes
the overlap between efficiency the
embrace of standardization
and the particular and a conception of
information as something discrete the
vertical filing cabinet and the tabbed
manila folder emerge from this overlap
between efficiency and this new idea of
information and the file draw granular
certainty created a particular cabinet
logic and here we just have an ad for um
150 and 200 division um tabbed folders
for um alphabetical order of names so
breaking the alphabet down not into 26
letters but into 150 or 250
categories so this cabinet logic used
paper manila folders tabs to create
partitions within a cabinet drawer to
decrease discretion and increase
certainty
in promotional literature
this cabinet logic became quote the
intellect of the filing cabinet to help
market the filing cabinet as a machine
now um
as these quotes here show ads emphasize
that the filing cabinet will
anthropomorphize the filing cabinet
right
as lisa gittleman points out um the word
automatic came into general use in the
19th century derived from
autonomaton sorry um that so that is
that the increasing use of automatic
carried with it quote lingering
connotations of resolving the organic
and the mechanical of human forms and
functions built into machinery and of
mechanical responses by human beings
so as a machine because that's how the
filing cabinet was often marketed it
took on the work of remembering right um
in her 1923 book filing department
operation and control um ethel schoff
scofield scofield argued that with the
increased scale and expectation of 20th
century corporate capitalism an
individual businessman could no longer
depend on his memory to recall all
aspects of his business with the detail
that 20th century capitalism demanded
scofield noted that replacing this
memory quote presupposes a thoroughgoing
automatic system for the association of
ideas close quote posing the question
can such a thing be secured by
mechanical means she immediately answers
experience tells us yes therefore
scofield calls vertical files and
automatic memory
now automatic in this case really does
mean predetermined and taking on the
role of thinking of remembering from
people
remembering where information was
located
office equipment identified as a machine
was understood to guarantee order this
was
petitions and tabs generating granular
certainty
which in the name of efficiency and
saving time directed the user to where
the needed information could be found
we're now transitioning to the second
part of the talk information labor
now that user was understood as someone
who operated a machine hence the
importance of the hands of the operator
the hands that had to pick up and hold
paper and information
james mccord who founded the new york
school of filing this might be another
thing either yes they taught filing in
high schools um and there were private
schools in 1914 he used his textbook to
stress the need for a clerk to possess
physical dexterity i'm not going to read
the quote in full but the point here is
that although the filing cabinet lacked
the mechanical parts that underscored um
scientific management celebration of
dexterity in the factory mccord's
description illustrates the importance
of hands and fingers to filing in the
office right filing demanded more than
the mere handling of paper it involves
selecting grasping removing lifting
placing
fingering drawing pudding
right so fingers displace objects and
eyes fingers grasp and displace objects
they isolate them and they gather them
together they manipulate and shape
objects so guided by the intellect of
the filing cabinet the hands of a file
clerk manipulated information not in the
sense of falsifying information but in
the sense of handling it of moving
information within the office
this is a period when the concept of
workflow emerges
a whole lot in the book about that the
granular certainty that uh articulated
information as a discrete object via
loose paper also underwrote the labor of
the file clerk whose work enabled its
circulation and in fact the file click
emerges or as a distinct occupational
category because the work of the 19th
century clerk a man was broken down into
a number of distinct specialized tasks
including typing bookkeeping and filing
to be done by woman
so filing as an example filing was an
example of clerical work that emphasized
the necessity of particular bodies
interacting with a machine the action of
these bodies was also separated into
discrete parts to better manage their
labor following the logic of granular
certainty so in the words of one filing
manual author mind eye and hand can soon
be trained so that they automatically
act together to do the teamwork that is
invaluable now the brain is part of this
team but only because as labour
historian harry braverman argues to the
extent that clerical work quote is still
performed in the brain the brain is used
as the equivalent of the hand of the
factory worker in an assembly line
this idea of filing is informational
labor
i use information labor to label office
work as it was redefined as machine work
now information labor is not a distinct
occupational category rather i use the
term to refer to a type of instrumental
encounter between workers and
information that became increasingly
common throughout the 20th century and
is still with us in the 21st century in
its ideal form this is an encounter that
requires neither thought nor
interpretation
and does not directly produce knowledge
a product of discourses of system and
efficiency it fits into a conception of
work that depends on rational and
calculated procedures so information
work is not knowledge work and nor is
information work men's work this is very
clear in the advertisements that
introduce the filing cabinet and the
work associated with it gender
underwrote the distinction between
information labor and knowledge work in
the office
identifying it as women's work
reinforced its secondary status men
could do these tasks but they were
things a man aka a knowledge worker
could do on the side without any thought
a catalog description for a so-called
efficiency desk which included file jaws
made this point with the lack of
subtlety that is critical to the genre
of the trade catalogue
quote each compartment should represent
a fixed place so that the hand of the
executive will reach automatically for
desired records without interrupting the
continuity of brain action
in this scenario a man filed but only
while he thought about something else he
reached over to the draw as a matter of
habit while the file drawer as a machine
worked to locate information for him a
file jaw remembered that allowed the
male executive to keep thinking about
matters deemed productive as an
executive in the gendered office
hierarchy a man was employed to think
his work was the priority of the office
promotions for the filing cabinet
further emphasized it was designed as an
object to be used by women
some catalogues claimed that women's
bodies affected the dimensions of the
filing cabinet so the cabinet should
only be four jaws high because quote
that is about as high as an ordinary
girl can work to advantage
similarly a draw was only 27 inches long
because it could be pulled quote by the
file clerk as an arm operation any
longer it would become a walking
operation meaning the clerk would have
to move to the side of the draw to reach
into the back so therefore um in case
you have been wondering all your life
what is the vanishing point of utility
the vanishing point of utility is very
close to 27 inches it's not 27 inches
but it's very very close
um in another type of ad manufacturers
sometimes used a close-up of the
interior of a file drawer to illustrate
how a cabinet worked so they could claim
their folders guides and tabs and
follower blocks as unique and in these
ads a woman's body disappeared though
her arms and hands might remain and in
this example she is literally erased
from the image now while the close-up of
the draw was arguably necessary to show
the guides and tabs the fact it removed
the body from the image meant that the
pair of disembodied but gendered arms
and hands not only pointed out the
cabinet logic of the interior of the
draw but also shows us show us the ideal
relationship between labor and
technology necessary for the cabinet to
be labeled automatic
hands or arms separated from their
bodies and minds suggested that the user
the users of this office equipment did
not have to think um as they worked
therefore a disembodied hands um in
filing advertisements represented work
that was neither independent nor
constructive
as janet zandi argues quote truncated
hands represent metanomically and
ignored whole a lesser human element and
species
since the 17th century this truncation
has been applied to workers where
they're identified as hired hands or
simply hands
in filing an information labor it was
only natural in this period that these
hands would belong to women
advocates invoked as common sense an
association between a woman's hands and
dexterity to naturalize the construction
of the new machine based
work or sorry to naturalize the new
machine-based information work as
feminine occupations by 1943 evelyn
steele editorial director of vocational
guidance research could confidently note
quote it is generally agreed that women
do well at painstaking tedious work
requiring patience and dexterity of the
hands the actual fact that women's
fingers are more slender than men makes
a difference close quote now this idea
was usually linked to um to work in
leisure activities the former invoke
women's work in light manufacturing or
textiles for the latter it was often
noted that socially acceptable leisure
practices provided ways for women to
enhance their apparent natural dexterity
and thus gain informal training and
filing as one manager commented i often
ask a girl if she plays the piano or if
she knits crochet sews or does another
type of work that would enable her to
acquire speed with her fingers
shockingly despite this natural
connection between feminine hands and
hands and files sometimes the automatic
memory of the filing cabinet failed when
it did those hands were explicitly
reconnected to a body and this filing
was the fault of the file clerk never
the filing cabinet or the filing system
oops
as a mode of misuse and error misfiling
is what victoria owell olwell calls a
bodily malfunction that is the cloak of
invisibility covering the body drops
away the moment the body makes a mistake
so misfiling makes visible a very
particular body that of a young woman as
one company magazine asked can misfile
misfile
the answer was yes
and it was due to her use and her miss
unmarried status this was the very same
use however that was of course critical
to her efficiency or at least the cost
efficiency of her labor the work of file
clerks was efficient in part because
dominant beliefs about gender and
sexuality lowered its cost
file clerks were poorly paid not only
because they were women and young but
also because they were unmarried what ma
hicks calls quote an assumed
heteronormativity created a family wage
and an informal marriage bar that is a
young woman was never assumed to be a
household's main breadwinner so it
didn't matter what you paid her and once
married she would of course stop working
at the office either by choice or force
and go and stay home and look after her
husband and the kids that would
inevitably follow
so this unmarried status and the
assumption that all women wanted to
marry men was viewed as the immediate
cause of filing so from this perspective
unmarried women who worked close to men
could be distracted while they thought
about potential husbands
around them surveys of women office
workers did support the belief that
marriage was a priority for young women
who worked in offices but it is not
clear if it dictated their actions in
the office
assuming that marriage-dominated
thoughts of female clerks work advice
literature focused on managing female
desire
unwanted sexual advances and harassment
from men were not behaviours to be
managed or even publicly discussed it
was the responsibility of women to curb
their emotions and quote the feminine
instinct to attract to awaken a response
close quote in a space whereas the male
manager of an employment service
possibly this guy in the photo here put
it women were hired to quote add to the
general attractiveness of the office
an experienced female office manager
instructed um
file clerks quote to
leave fine clothes the theater pleasant
parties and tom dick and eric harry at
home which also raises the idea that our
clerks have quite home life i think with
tom dick and harry with them
this was necessary because if a woman
brought such thoughts into the office it
would break down the teamwork of senses
and the mind quote as she says here
important tasks cannot be accomplished
with your hands while unimportant
details fill your head you cannot file
amusement under work they are at the
extremes of the alphabet she must have
been very proud of that line um thus
miss file would misfile if she failed to
compartmentalize if she failed to keep
her personal concerns and work duties in
their proper place and order that is the
explanation for her behavior invoked the
very act of misfiling right of putting
something um in the wrong place
perhaps it's not surprising that the
filing cabinet was offered as a tool to
teach young women to better order their
lives by controlling their thoughts and
desires especially when these women were
often the daughters of immigrants
working in a space coded as middle class
an office manager argued that office
technologies would teach these young
women quote the three necessities of
efficiency concentration accuracy and
good nature she explained concentration
as the need to control your thoughts as
you must your pencil with a firm grip
despite outside disturbance and inward
annoyance i think we've all felt that
however it was not only office
technologies like the pencil and the
filing cabinet that could teach women
the necessity of efficiency when a woman
left the office as apparently she would
to become a wife and mother she used new
domestic storage technologies that
reinforced the value of productivity and
efficiency in the 1920s storage in the
home changed dramatically prior to this
storage spaces were not affected into
the design of houses so for example
closets and cabinets were not designed
to store specific objects
this changed as the cabinet logic of
designated places and partitions and
office furniture became critical to how
spaces were managed and objects stored
in the home this was seen for example in
response to the early 20th century
closet problem
previously after thoughts or a little
more than wall cavities
closets became purpose-built they were
organized they the enclosed spaces of
closets were organized into smaller
spaces just think ikea catalog right
however the main action in terms of home
storage was in the kitchen as kitchen
design became a thing that filled the
pages of house and garden house
beautiful ladies home journal etc
it began with standalone cabinets that
turned kitchen storage into the
strategic use of shelves drawers and
partitions in this way the modern
kitchen was linked to the office through
a faith in a cabinet logic that
prioritized meticulously organized
interior storage
to make things accessible this was
captured in the hoosier cabinet
six foot high and four feet wide um its
large shelves and drawers house such
items as pans kettles and nests of
mixing bowls all in specially designed
spaces promotional materials claim that
a hoosier cabinet had 400 articles all
within
an arm's reach
manufacturers and writers were keen to
acknowledge the debt to the office
vertical or upright partitions called
files were added shelves we still see
them sometimes today that allows plates
and platters to be stored on its edge
quote you can pick out with one hand
just the dish that you want
ads to be expected were much more
succinct the business of getting meals
the kitchen needs to be business-like
and in this ad we can see a little cut
out of an office um with a filing
cabinet and with the vertical
verticality of the skyscraper as well
now as implied when announcing the move
from the office to the home what i see
them important in these changes
in home storage is that they illustrate
that storage technologies require a
certain form of labor performed by a
particular worker storage is not mutual
an encounter with these technologies
encourage women to understand their
self-worth through productivity as the
interaction between hand and object
became the representation of efficient
labor in the home these economic values
became a way to express identity
addressed in this way
these women participated in a
reconfiguration of attitudes towards
self and work performance that helped
make productivity common sense an
adjustment that mel greg argues gives
productivity its 20th century
history
i want to go further and link these
changes to information right to say
although changes in domestic storage did
not address information as a formal
category they do offer a suggestive
example of how people experience modern
information
via the materiality of storage
technologies right so granular certainty
cabinet logic moved to the house and
brought with it a particular form of
work centered on an idea of the
particular and the specific
by way of conclusion
i want to restate some key arguments by
briefly discussing two of my favorite
research discoveries that i couldn't fit
in the in the paper earlier now the
first um is a trade catalog from a
michigan based company called shaw
walker in the early 20th century they
advertised their filing equipment under
the slogan built like a skyscraper i can
explain later what that means if you are
really curious um the cam a campaign
the reason i'm interested in this is his
campaign places filing at the center of
the gender division of the modern office
albeit from the perspective of the mail
the built like a skyscraper campaign
constructed of a series of physical
encounters um between male and female
bodies and the companies filing cabinets
to illustrate different aspects of the
essentials of office equipment strength
rigidity easy operation noiselessness
economy of floor space maximum capacity
and good design because we always think
of good design when we look at a filing
cabinet so it showed men
jumping into open drawers
lifting their bodies off the ground and
hanging from open drawers what the
catalog calls handstands
the latter image we use to signify the
rigidity of the drawers as opposed to
the strength of the drawers illustrated
by men jumping into them i'm going to
come back to this but i just want to say
other companies did something similar
using photographs of men sitting or
standing um in the open drawers of their
filing cabinets the point of this um
was
purportedly to show that a filing
cabinet was built to hold the weight of
paper because four drawers each drawer
weighing 75 pounds isn't a really is it
a lot there's a lot of weight and you
want to know that not only will the
filing cabinet fall apart but the drawer
can open smoothly against the little
girl um down the bottom there but i
would suggest the filing the built like
a skyscraper campaign is not subtle at
all in the ways that it represented
these issues right it doesn't take much
i think that anyone armed with some
basic theories of gender representation
to argue that this brief exercise
routine
and the advertisements seem to reflect
the anxiety that men felt about the
arrival of women clerical workers um in
offices the phallic skyscraper the
unsheathed tip of the woolworth building
in the background the rigid and erect
male athletic body all sort i would
suggest humbly to make explicit the
masculinity of the men who worked
in the office
um such masculinity was not to be
questioned
and this is reinforced by the image the
campaign uses to demonstrate the easy
operation of the filing cabinet where
not only do they ch choose a woman or a
female body to open the file door they
choose a child they choose a child
pulling on a silk thread
the idea being here that i think you
know if a child can do it anyone could
operate a filing cabinet if anyone can
file if filing requires only the
strength and the intellect of a girl
then only women should file because men
can do other work that women can't do
the second find i want to finish with is
a nationally syndicated cartoon from
1921 reprinted and had his favorite
magazine filing
that ran for four years as part of a
failed attempt to get filing recognized
as a profession
the cartoon in a very odd way can be
used to illustrate the effects of
capitalism on information or rather the
changing shape of capitalism on
information so in it we see here a mail
file clerk um quits after his boss
refuses to increase his pay before he
leaves in an act of defiance he removes
the papers from the filing cabinet and
throws them around the office in the
final two panels the boss changes his
mind and the clerk gets the news of his
pay increase while surrounded by loose
papers and files this image stood out to
me when i found it because when the boss
makes the decision to increase the file
clerk's pay he calls him mr google
right um and then the coincidence of the
name google being associated with access
to information is pretty uncanny which
and it became basically ridiculous when
it's digit the image itself as we can
see is digitized by google right um so
yes this board is on the ridiculous this
coincidence but i also find it a useful
way to illustrate that categories of
information overload and information
management take vastly different forms
at different historical moments at one
time as i've argued the filing cabinet
was the symbol of orderly information
management by the end of the 20th
century google search has taken that
mantle and the comic strip mr google
sabotages the filing system right by
spilling papers out of their proper
locations ironically this results in
exactly the kind of giant pile of papers
i either wear but made up of pages that
google the
corporation i know it's technically
alphabet but that ruins my point here
google the corporation provides access
to through page rank the chaos mr google
creates is exactly the chaos that
google later on promises to manage
that is although different both the
filing cabinet and the search engine
became organizing principles for the
capitalist management of information
and i will stop there
uh
which is a
filing cabinet
makes this emergence in the 1890s
um at the same time that batting
machines telephones elevators
typewriters like all the machinery of
modern offices are happening at once and
do you think
is there a connection across these
machines that you think is important or
is the filing cabinet sort of
uber machine or machine
and i think there are connections and
there are things that make the filing
cabinet um unique so i think the
connection between all of those things
is that the operation of those machines
is what i call information labor right
so this is this moment in which this
this this very sort of instrumental
encounter interaction with information
comes to define work and you don't have
to necessarily like understand the the
context or i mean or the content of what
you're doing you're just helping these
information circular so i think that
that connects them um and so in that
sense i'm implicitly arguing that
they're all
they're all
connect they're all in some way making
manifest a particular idea of
information distinct from knowledge what
makes the filing cabinet a particularly
useful example of that moment is the way
in which it allows us to really
understand the sense of information
right in such a significant way that the
filing cabinet the files the tabs the
the folders continue as i said at the
beginning of the talk to sort of these
are the ways in which we're asked to
think about our encounters with
information so that to me is what the
the way the filing cabinet caught up
stands out and i think it is important i
mean the final camera is
arguably more important if we think
about storage and the value of storage
because that's where information is
stored right like the filing cabinet
becomes absolute absolutely critical
infrastructure to allow
like the you know to allow the modern
world to function right like it's
critical to governance it's critical to
corporations right because that's how
information is stored and retrieved and
um you know if if there was another
technology that did that then i probably
would have written about that in in one
sense but the filing cabinet did and of
course like all infrastructure it's kind
of ignored right it's just this thing in
the corner and the labor associated with
it isn't it
that strikes me so fascinating oh yeah
that paper is like a filing cabinet that
files the people and you need that you
know
that you know you need the elevators to
get people to the 20th floor so they can
work so they can go in their slot for
beautiful their whatever be in their
spot
yeah exactly and that's what i mean like
the first chapter of the book after the
introduction is called verticality and
it explores all those connections right
and in fact to the point that i sort of
argue that when capitalism takes on its
20th century form it has a vertical bias
right um you know and and i think we can
see that in all the things that you
mentioned like the skyscraper here that
i put up on the screen and and the
elevator um but also um thinking about
um with a filing cabinet but also
thinking about uh management hierarchy
right the vertical ladder like you know
verticality i really do think it has a
vertical bias until the network
arguably comes in as a
various hurricane and she moves up in
the building the camera shows outside
the building it goes up it's it's
amazing i will stop my happily no no
it's great no yeah
yeah
and then we have some cues uh people
queued up in our q a as well
hi
um so i want to talk a little about the
haptic element of some of your arguments
this idea of touch and sort of storage
and touch and how they were related and
kind of bringing it to contemporary
storage of the cloud and the drive and
the sort of it's the reality of that
right like the non-existence of a touch
but in fact there are hard drives
right that you know contain the data and
i guess i wonder like do you see the non
of contemporary legends see contemporary
storage practices non-active ones
i mean do you see them as as changing
this this this kind of vertical
structure of capitalism or not like um
yeah i think that um i always
i always have to you know um
begin hesitantly begin these these
questions because i you know i am a
historian by trade right so like i
obviously i think about and i come to
this through
contemporary questions and issues but
you know it's not it's not where my head
fully goes so yeah part of the thing
part of the point i want to talk about
here is that when i'm arguing that
storage is not neutral and the ways that
you've just talked about contemporary
stories not being neutral it speaks to
you know like different values or
different ways in which storage has been
defined right so the notion of
verticality i think is absolutely
central to how
storage is understood within the context
of capitalism right in the early 20th
century i think as capitalism changes
and i sort of you know just direct when
i was talking
to the responding to hear this points
you know saying that like in the middle
of the 20th century or the second half
of the 20th century the network we can
argue becomes important and then you can
think about a horizontal bias you know
and then you know and then you know the
cloud you know and then we can think
about concepts of the cloud and that
less tangible understanding
of storage is another further
development an issue i think it really
affects
how we think about storage right if
because the things aren't piling up
there you know you don't
turn around and have an entire wall of
cds or an entire wall of records right
and so so that lack of um like that the
the lessening of that haptic dimension
to that individual specific item of
storage i think completely alters how we
think about storage right it makes
storage live in a way that the filing
cabinet you know is not at all but i
think you you noted this too but there's
still we can't deny the haptic dimension
that is still there you know in terms of
how we how we access things but yeah so
so definitely i mean i think these are
issues and part of what i always you
know every in a historian's hope right
is that people who are much more
invested in contemporary issues can take
some of the concepts that history has
allowed us as historians to think about
and you know and apply them you know and
really develop them
um
but yeah i could go on with that and i
may if there are no other hands
that are virtual uh yeah
you have a question that i missed the
first couple of minutes of yeah
apparently
so
you know i was wondering what was there
a specific company behind promoting
those because you know it's it's
connected to my my real question is to
what extent
that system of the vertical filing the
filing cabinet also translates to other
countries right which has to do of
course with that capitalistic idea of
company you know promoting those those
ideas in terms of frequency sure yeah so
so the medical filing cabinet is an
american invention right it comes out
through the 1890s there's not really one
there's not you know it's it's it's very
much of its time so there wasn't really
one inventor per se though if you go to
wikipedia there's a nice invention story
for you and it is actually kind of
appealing because they credited the
company they credited to is a company
called the library bureau
which was founded by melville dewey of
the dewey decimal system right even
though he was no longer part of the
company when um they were um when they
were attributed with inventing the
filing cabinet it also links it to the
library and the card catalog and all
those things so you have so the flying
cabinet really does take off as an
american product and and builds this
office equipment company office
equipment industry most of the um
companies are based either in the
midwest or um in upstate new york for
for a variety of reasons by the 1920s um
the vertical filing cabinet is starting
to be exported right um and it has an
impact um in europe but you know if you
have lived in europe you know that the
vertical file there is not the vertical
filing cabinet right it's the arch
binder right um and that's the
archbinder that in some ways cornelia
wiesman in in her canonical book files
which is sort of a media archaeology of
the legal file like she talks about
vertical files and that but they're the
binders right so i have not explored and
i'm not going to um play with
stereotypes to you know you know um to
figure out why it is in in in
many countries the file remains that
binder concept versus the draw but i if
that was part of your question i i
definitely absolutely acknowledge that
that distinction yeah
maybe it's the lack of skyscrapers
is there another question over there
yeah hi yeah um so i know that like
modern filing cabinets have the safety
feature where you can't open like
multiple doors at once did that um like
start when it was first invented or like
did that come later yeah that's that's a
great question about sort of security
and privacy right which of course is
another important key aspect of storage
often so um what the initial initial
filing cabinets didn't come with locks
and this was a concern about security
locks came in but it was it was it was
just simply a lock that locked all four
you locked all four drawers right um and
um it's yeah sorry was that what you
were asking with when they you can only
pull out one at a time
um when you open multiple doors and
wrist top lane dropping it over yeah oh
sorry yeah yeah yeah so it did not have
that mechanism sorry i i misunderstood
yeah so it had a lot to lock for um to
lock four drawers but no it's well into
the 20 middle of the 20th century when
you they developed the mechanism to stop
them all coming out and so that is that
concern right of them toppling over
which is part of what those guys doing
their their handstands right you know
and and pull-ups on the and jumping into
the filing cabinet is meant to say hey
you know look this drawing of a man you
know shows that all these photographs
these people sitting in show that it can
take this weight and it's not sorry it's
not going to tip over
so was that did i get to it eventually
or was it yeah yeah sorry about that
[Music]
as professor craig can you cite one
example of partiality
uh that you found
practicality partiality
looking at a information story
an example of passion yeah sorry i i'm a
little lost on that question could we
yeah
if you have another
word or
an update to that
bias i know like it's there but ah so ah
so okay i'll i'll keep answering yeah
bye okay thank you thank you okay
viruses that you found in the looking
okay um
maybe
maybe i kind of spoke too loosely in the
talk maybe this is where this question
came from um i think
so yes i mean of course the information
within the file the thought and file
cabinets can represent multiple biases
right um that the um argument about
information being objective right is
that information is something that can
exist separate from the context in which
it's created so that it can be
interpreted very easily right so this
idea of information is something
different from knowledge is information
having as having sort of effectivity
right like so it's not data but it has
effectivity so i was talking when i was
talking about it being objective i was
talking about the conception of
information right um as an entity as a
thing not the actual if you like
stuff on the piece of paper does does
that make sense
i mean i don't know if that makes sense
so so yeah there's a lot of bias in in
the in the within the information within
the files and folders themselves
i'm just going to keep moving through
images up here
where did you go to find that
origin of information as a concept
right so i'm i'm drawing pretty heavily
on the work of jeff nunberg for this
jeffrey number um it's an essay called
farewell to the information age and a
book he co-edited with poor do good i
think
called um the future of the book that
came out in the early 1990s right and
it's this beautifully written essay
that is incredibly smart and has shaped
a lot of the work and media studies um
the work of people looking at the
intersection of paper and information so
someone like lisa gilman um for example
um and so um yes and so nunberg is
arguing that that in this period um as i
i think i mentioned very quickly in the
talk in the 19th century information
moves from being a process right being
informed being educated to being a thing
to being something that you can possess
and that is that it's something that can
exist or that is an entity and there's a
also a special
issue of the journal history of human
sciences i think which goes through and
talks about the development of in the
19th century um of the idea of data
through the use of of the way in which
the census in europe and the united
states comes to be represented so again
you've got tables right that are all
representing information you know as
something that is discrete right that
has therefore some kind of presence in
the world right and as understood that
the idea is that you can look at the
stuff at a glance right meaning you as
um
as uh john celie brown and paul do good
put it like you know knowledge needs a
noah right it needs a subject it needs a
person but information doesn't have a
noah right it doesn't have a per you
know it's understood to be this thing
that exists in the world and so what i
find fascinating about the filing
cabinet is that through the concept of
the file this kind of sort of abstract
understanding of information is
something distinct from knowledge that's
starting to percolate through society
from the middle of the 19th century on
suddenly there's a tangible way you can
conceive of it right because now you
have this loose piece of paper you know
in a in a file folder in a drawer and
you can extract this one piece of paper
versus having to get the entire you know
big bound book and have to look through
it and scroll through it so that it's
that idea of the particularity of paper
i think helps underscore this notion of
information as a discrete unit now i'm
pushing it a bit further with the file
cabinet but other people um have made
you know a similar argument in that
sense and i think it's a really
attractive and appealing argument and
for me what i find particularly
fascinating is in this period as i read
through the literature the word
information is being used but so is
knowledge and so is data and that and it
might be like in instrumental knowledge
or structured knowledge or organized
knowledge there's just a struggle people
are fumbling around to try and name
something that's new that's the way i
read it right and so and then
information becomes the thing you know
that that is the name for that kind of
specificity that isn't numerical right
that isn't data so data takes on that in
the early 20th century takes on on on
that name and so you know like no one in
the early 20th century is saying they're
living in an information age or an
information society but again i think
you know part of the way i locate the
book is in what i call
the genealogy of the ascendance of
modern information right so this is a
very particular my period and an
important period in that moment before
we go to you know to to um the middle of
the 20th century you know and
information becomes um
you know information becomes
i can't think of anyone's names you know
mit guys i'm completely blanking you
know where information becomes something
that you yes yes but these massive huge
figures where information becomes
something that you can measure and
that's another form a technical form of
information which is also part of the
story but i think this preceding that is
an important part of the story just to
be able to think about information as a
unit
even if that unit becomes something
different because of the work that
happens around here
yeah
if you look at any like
other versions of information that can
beat it with uh with the imaginary
informational hospital cabinet and if
they were saying other artifacts
yeah so i mean so the card catalog right
becomes is it's key to that right and
and businesses are using card
like that you know businesses still use
the equivalent of a library card catalog
often to record the the um the ledger
the bound book ledger can become a
cartilager right i mean there are many
ways in which you know the cabinet comes
in um the card catalog cabinet or
versions of it come into the office so
that's the i think that's the other
really main sort of competing thing the
punch card right is is the other one
right but punch cards in this period
they're really not in a lot of
businesses compared to the filing
cabinet and the card catalog but yes
those i mean those i think those are two
other if you like competing ways of of
of conceit of of thinking about this
conception of information but they
definitely don't have the sort of um
uptake
um
that the filing cabinet does and then of
course what makes the filing cabinet
interesting looking back is the fact
that files and tabs etc
are how we still think about information
we don't think about the card right you
know like scrivener might want us to go
back and think about you know the card
but we don't think about a card or a
catalog in that way and the punch card
you know like whereas we do think about
the file you know in multiple ways both
as the icon on our desktop but also the
directory system right
and again liz liesman's book file it's
only
if you i don't read german well enough
to read the german there's a longer
version where i think she expands a
little bit more on this but an english
translation is just a very short nod to
the current moment but she really traces
a history um through legal records and
the registry of the idea of the file in
terms of directory nesting structure
whereas sort of i'm looking
via the filing cabinet more is the file
as icon on on the desktop right
and folder in the desktop so yeah
um can you talk
uh
more about the gender as a uh
uh or not just
feminine female sexuality as a problem
um you
referenced um you know unwanted advances
sort of an issue but also you said they
were undiscussed in a way so there's the
the the problem that a woman naturally
brings this sort of
threat because she's she's feminine and
irresistible and she brings it to the
office and it has to be managed but it
doesn't seem to be
they're trying it it feels like you're
trying to downplay that because if you
open that up it becomes too much of a
threat too dangerous and i'm thinking
i'm just wondering how
much there is ambivalence there
but as i immediately started thinking
once again about halloween films and
specifically from like the 1929-33
period before the production code
where
you do have films like babydoll that i
reckless where the woman who is the
secretary who files and answers the
phone whatever is inherently
a sexual threat a sexual danger in the
workplace right but then you have quite
a few films that are ambivalent
and and really it has to do with like
how you script the film you need to the
the sort of bad though
right and so the film skyscraper souls
is like the perfect example of this
right sorry warren williams the ultimate
cad
greatest boss figure of these pre-code
movies right
who
you know you have the secretary
struggling not to be raped and then you
have the old hand he's been through
several bosses and she's part of the job
you know
it's heard that right um and the film
acknowledges it as horrific
um there's just this sort of fascinating
ambivalence about women in this
corporate workplace that you see in
popular culture and i'm just curious how
much of that ambivalence really comes
through in all the
interesting sources
yes so so so my comments are about um
sort of the
about
the harassment you know which you know
this image here right of this creepy guy
just staring at this woman and her she
refusing to make eye contact this is an
ad to make you want to buy a filing
cabinet right um like so but a lot but a
lot of that stuff draws from secondary
sources right so which you may or may
not be familiar with um lisa fine wrote
a book which looks at and analyzes all
of these films and other popular
cultural artifacts at the time um sharon
strom is where i took a lot of the
comment about um
about not discuss like being
acknowledged but not discussing the
behavior of men um so in the but in the
sources that i found so i was looking at
vocational sources right so vocational
literature and all the how-to office
manuals and all this all the literature
that was out there to recruit um women
into um the office and in that there was
no ambivalence right like you know the
responsibility was squarely on the
shoulders of women to um behave
themselves and as i said that quote like
you know to check their apparently you
know natural desire to throw themselves
you know at any man um and this was
fought through clothes right that's what
like so what clothes were acceptable to
be worn and
worn in the office right and that was in
that quote about as well as leaving tom
dick and harry at home you left all your
fancy clothes at home right and so that
becomes a site where people um yeah a
site of struggle over where where it
seems that female workers are trying to
express some sense of themselves through
the through their sexuality right but um
but yeah i didn't um so yeah i did not
find um that that ambivalence that um
that you can't you're right that is
there in in my underst you know in my
limited understandings of those films
and that's sort of a whole sub-genre of
the office wife right which you know
there's in fact one i think called the
office wife and then there are you know
that's a recurring character right where
we are you know she is the threat in the
sense you know like she is she's become
his wife in the office right it's not
you know it's not my office buddy kind
of joking thing but you know today but
you know it's my office wife it's a
threat yeah i mean and this is of course
way outside your period but the
apartment from 1960 is
exactly what you're talking about or
what we're talking about here with the
gender issues of the boss running from
secretary of secretary and then you know
the secretary becomes the life slot and
then you need a new secretary for that
yeah to be your office wife yeah yeah so
and so it is set it's post code right
it's uh in 1960 and it can really sort
of
drill into this yeah yeah no so there's
a lot of dynamic and there are some
really smart histories of um
of essentially the history of you know
sexual harassment in the office right in
the modern office that have been written
coming largely coming out of um lit
under out of english literature but but
really interesting um ways where people
have explored this you know and um and
like i say to me in terms of that
literature this makes a very small
contribution by just saying well in this
vocational literature we can see this is
going on right and i think there is some
connection to the mode of work
that women are doing in the office
so filing was a magazine published for
four years um it um
it um it's published it's all on google
it's all you can it's gone on google
books um and it's all been scanned and
it ran for four years and it really was
part of an attempt to professionalize
filing so librarianship had just been
professionalized archivist work was
about to be professionalized and so
people wanted filing to be
professionalised and that's what this
magazine pushed they they were filing
associations founded in major cities
generally in the northeast they'd have
monthly meetings maybe 100 people would
show up maybe 20 people would show up a
guest person would go and deliver their
talk on this is how we file and you know
in the insurance company i work for you
know this is how we file in this church
right you know and they would meet once
a month and have a little chat and uh
you know and so that's um you know and
so that's where that magazine came from
but it's all up there if you want to
read and it just you know every it's a
clearinghouse for information about how
to file um and sadly i thought it would
play a bigger part in the book but it's
there when i talk about this failed
campaign um to professionalise
you know special training programs
because you mentioned that there is a
new profession emerging yeah
yeah so there's some so there's uh
so it fails right but but they are
trying to teach filing right and so the
um
the office equipment companies um create
different ways to teach fighting so this
is from lowell high school just up the
road in 1923 and they're using library
bureau equipment and what the library
bureau did which was really radical
right is that they reduced right letters
down to these small sizes right so you
would then file them in these boxes
because the problem was it was really
hard to teach filing because filing
cabinets took up so much space and you'd
have to line up to take your turn to
file the letter right and so they would
the um office equipment companies
constructed this these um courses right
that could run from 24 classes up to 72
or 96 class one hour classes in filing
now i didn't find any school or even any
private school that took up
96 lessons but they would incorporate
the lessons into
um
into the commercial education courses
that girls were being channeled into
because this is also a period like in
the beginning of the 20th century i
think it's five percent of american
teenagers go to high school so there's
this concerted effort to get kids into
high school and so this is where
vocational education emerges as as
something that's taught in high schools
so filing comes in as
in as part of that right and this is
also i found just as an aside complaints
from english professors and so forth
that they were being forced to teach
technical writing and all the stuff that
we maybe think of as a late nine late
20th century early 21st century problem
was a consequence of the success of
bringing in vocational um education so
by the 1930s
pushed along no doubt by the depression
about like 70 70 percent of teenagers
are in high school
i'm correct in recalling that this is
the same moment that home economics as a
field was invented right well yeah it's
a little early but again it takes off
right but i said same thing about how
can we keep people in high school like
we want them in high school and of
course what happens is the business
community shockingly takes over the
conversation and pushes it to a lot of
commercial education but women do filing
and typing and sorry girls do women are
filing and typing and boys do accounting
and management you know proto management
courses and things like this right so
yeah these are again as a there's a
there's a manual for teachers right um
and the bottom what these are the
letters and the thing is the letters can
be filed in different ways depending if
it's subject filing geographic filing
alphabetical name filing right um and so
it's again teaching the kids to very
quickly look they're taught to read very
quickly right they call it like the
dictionary or the um
direct telephone directory method where
you just look for the first three
letters of the last name to know where
it's going to go right you don't have to
read the whole thing again you don't
need to know right you're you're it's
this form of information labor
i could go on for hours
um the ways that we find resonance with
contemporary issues
that bounce back and forth and yeah you
know i'm thinking about big data and our
sense that now we have too much data we
didn't use that too much data but now
we're too much to get it and the the
paper
like there's just too much i mean
there's too much information if you need
to file 40 files in 60 seconds or
whatever yeah for one minute whatever it
is it's because there's just
an invaluable amount of information yeah
no it definitely is like it's a it's a
moment of information overload right um
you know and that's what i like about
the google comic strip like these
different modes of information overload
but i feel this is a really you can call
this information overload because it's
understood it's what's being overloaded
is understood as information not paper
right it's called that but if people
talk about information overload prior to
that they may be talking like it's
overwhelming amount of knowledge but
it's literally not called information by
the contemporary actors right and so i
think this is a real important example
uh you know of an early form you're
completely right of information overload
and the filing cabinet seeks to manage
that you know and you know and again it
comes up with this conception
what the funding came it doesn't but
what emerges as a conception of
information akin to data like you know
let's remove it from context so we can
better do something with it so let's
remove it from the context of a bound
volume of 19 you know of the
correspondence from the madrid office of
you know of the us embassy you know
where there might be
passport stuff in the middle of it but
it's all bound in this big book but now
we can isolate it as these discreet
things we don't need to understand the
context of what's going on in madrid in
the madrid office to understand this
thing about the filing about the
passport but the implication is we did
when it was a bound blog
i know i kind of lost you but possible
it's also great this is interesting so
i'm also wondering if you looked at sort
of power as it's coded in these in the
files themselves in the systems and i
asked that because
in i guess the early
20th century is still either
like a colonial colonialism
right so
and and we talk about information
overload but there's also information
access as it's opened up to a lot more
people and then also there's layers of
bias and algorithms i mean we could go
yeah
so much about it so i'm wondering like
are there are there ways that the
cabinet functioned as an exclusive space
just to hold information only accessible
to specific people
and are there you know what i mean other
ways we can understand that
exclusivity differently yeah and yeah
that's a great question and i i was kind
of surprised by that because i you know
i have for another set of reasons i have
a lot of interest um in the way in which
the archive has been thought about
particularly by historians of the
british empire right you know um and and
you know and other people like thinking
of ann and laura stoller and so forth
but particularly within the british
empire and and you know through the 19th
century again it's towards the end of
the 19th century that it but there's a
more systematic way to organize the
records of the british empire because
prior to that they're literally just
piles of paper dumped somewhere as these
reports that these poor colonial
has been forever crafting just get
arrive in london and just get put in a
pile right um so i was expecting and
maybe thinking that i would find
something you know something connected
to that to the very question you're
asking but in the literature that i was
looking at i didn't find it now
you know i'm not
writing a history of classification i am
writing a history of storage so so that
negates part of what you said but still
where you ended up the final point of
your question i think is really
important and so you know i found you
know the closest i got was just finding
you know debates and concerns about
security and privacy just sort of in
general right um within an office so
right to a filing cabinet there was
discussions of private filing you know
the private filing cabinet of a man in
his office separate from the larger
filing cabinets of you know the the
battery or as they called them you know
the dozens of fighting candidates that
occupied the center space you know of an
office right but yeah surprisingly and
it's not to say it's not there it just
wasn't there
in the literature that i that i was
looking at but i think it you know it is
a it is a really really important
question about like how the filing
cabinet is a mode of storage is
understood to exclude right you know in
terms of the like access and type of
knowledge right because these women have
all this this is something that isn't
again you know i'm looking at the ideal
representation of it to make an argument
um but you know these women
while the idea is set up that they can
look they can move they have to file
really quickly right but they do
ultimately have access
to all this stuff
right and there is sadly it's actually
not one of the ones i pulled up here and
didn't use but there's a um a great ad
that i i found from the mid 1930s from
one company where it's like
she controls your history right
um you know and so you know so then you
know this like in in that kind of
playful way there's a like a little bit
of an acknowledgement of it but no i'm
rambling on because i like i think it's
a great question but yeah i can't i
can't give you something about other
than
recognize the the question the insight
okay
um did you see any instances of fighting
travels being used
uh or subversive or illicit purposes
within corporations i'm curious about
how they might have been repurposed by
employees yeah and she says this
question might be redundant considering
what you're currently saying yeah yeah
no it's i mean it is kind of right yeah
but again um i didn't you know that
part of it is the limitations of the
archive right so the archive skews to
the official literature you know in the
sense right and so you know i and it's
it's hard you know like
i i really didn't find like diaries or
or journals or or something where that
might be recorded or i was also looking
at the you know i was looking at the
archives of such as they were of the
companies the filing equipment companies
like the book would never have been
written if i was going to choose you
know to really take a deep dive into
various companies and how file cabinets
were used so that's you know that that's
where i may have found that right but
what i didn't find in the how to
literature or the or the literature in a
magazine like filing or any or its
successor the file um
which was more of a pamphlet was that i
didn't find people
addressing that as a problem which
doesn't mean as when we were talking
about you know the harassment of men
sexual harassment it doesn't mean that
it wasn't a problem but it definitely
wasn't a problem that was that was
talked about um
but yeah so all that comes in is
misfiling which is understood to be a
distraction
right like from distraction not not
intentional there's not an intentional
thing you know it's a distraction or
it's there or it's stupid
right like like a lack of you know i
sort of yeah because these are the
daughters of immigrants right so it's a
lot of race i mean i focused on gender
today but obviously it goes you know it
goes hand in hand um with race ethnicity
and as i did sort of briefly not to
sexuality
well i think that we're uh right pushing
up at 6 30 so i just want to thank craig
robinson again for joining us and i'll
see you all
next
uh time and our distance folks at our
closing week after this
thank you so much